if you're going to go on raya here's the
thing
these so-called anonymous places where
so-called
well-known people oh yes yes yes we have
our own little island
called the the the celebrity island that
they it's great there how great is that
honestly that's the best version of the
bachelor is the island
bachelor in paradise jen joked dodging
the dating app question
and shut down this idea for a bachelor
spin-off
imagine if all celebrities just lived on
one island and you couldn't get off
well no i mean that would be not great
for anybody
as for rumors jen's hanging out with ex
john mayer again
well she avoided that as well john got
fans buzzing when he posted this tick
tock video
and some pointed out how much the dog in
the video looks
just like jen's even the same collar but
when jen was asked about the collars
she said my trainer's friend makes them
i've received a lot of questions about
the dog collars
the actress goes full glam for the
september issue of instyle
and also weighs in on britney spears
jen says the media took advantage of
brit and
other 90s pop stars quote half of these
kids started on the mickey mouse club
brittany aniston adds i was lucky enough
to be raised by a very strict mother
the priorities were not about becoming a
famous person it was
study your craft learn what you're doing
don't just go out there and get lucky
and jen's got nothing but respect for
j.lo
who she says has hollywood's best red
carpet pose
quote she fell out of bed that way she's
a performer
and we're learning more about the
jewelry ben apparently gave j.lo for her
birthday
the pieces are reportedly by the jeweler
found rey and include this
18 karat gold golden key symbolizing
true love
plus this resilience medallion which
includes blossoms which are fed with
passion and continue to bloom even
against adversity
but now to jlo's ex diddy he says
no he was not taking a shot at benifer
when he posted this throwback with jlo
back in may
yes it was right around the time the
couples started making headlines
sean says quote it wasn't no trolling
involved that's just my friend
adding i don't have nothing to say about
her relationship or her life
the 51 year old who changed his middle
name from john to
love is on the cover of vanity fair's
september issue on august 10th
oh my god
diddy posed with his three daughters and
had tips to style their hair
i said if beyonce ain't gonna wear it i
want it on them